best predictor of a child's future
wealth level when controlling for all of
the other variables is the average
income of the postcode that they grow up
in so it's the people around them the
nurture element of Nature and nurture
for children's upbringing seems to be
the friend groups that you put them in
so one of the first things that I would
do is I would go and vet very very
closely what are the coaches like at
every single different boxing gym
swimming gym gym gymnastics gym which is
the one that I think right he's got the
values he's the dad that's closest to me
that's what we did with that school yeah
we went to about four private schools
they were all driven by like the
education which is great for me I was
driven by the sports and the winning
side and the competitive all aspects of
it though who are the other kids that
are going what do the parents like that
go there this sounds bad but I would
very carefully vet the friends that
you're sending the kids around to they
can be from any background that you want
but you want the family to have the
right values you want them to be hard
working you don't want them to be
materialistic you don't want them to be
spending all of their time on their
phone etc etc